I want to talk a little bit about
the repercussions and the fallout,
including positive fallout from the
suspension of Donald Trump from Twitter.
Now we can have a reasonable debate about the
suspension of Donald Trump from Twitter. There's
no question that he did violate the terms and
conditions of Twitter and he's been violating
them for years. And if any non president were
doing that, they would have been suspended
from Twitter long ago. At the same time, the
counterpoint would be that there's value in
hearing from what world leaders say, and thus
the suspension is in some way a detriment to
knowing what it is that our leaders are feeling
and saying and doing or whatever the case may
be. I don't want to focus on that in this
particular segment because there have been a
lot of headlines floating around that election.
Misinformation has dropped dramatically
since Donald Trump was banned from Twitter. And
of course, that's true. It absolutely has. Online
misinformation about election fraud is down 73
percent after not only Twitter, but several social
media sites suspended Donald Trump about eight,
nine, ten days ago. This is based on a report from
Zainal Labs. And when you look at this, if you
believe that the sole cause of the reduction of
disinformation is Trump's suspension from these
platforms, that is a big endorsement of this as a
policy that if you identify particularly
important sort of nodes of disinformation by
getting rid of them, you stop the trickle down,
as it effectively is of disinformation. Trump
with what were, I think, 80 or something million
followers on Twitter would tweet disinformation.
And then these kind of next level people like his
family and prominent journalists and influencers,
would retweeting and signal boost the same bogus
ideas? And then you would have lower level media
and voters. And it continues and continues. And
next thing you know, you know, your great aunt
who's not even on Twitter is hearing about some
of these ideas Sunday morning on Fox Business to
point to Maria Bartiromo as as an example. I think
that the analysis has to go a little bit deeper,
though, because when Donald Trump was suspended
from Twitter and from these other platforms,
other things also went on that would explain
the dramatic reduction and disinformation around
the election. And we can't say it was merely
suspending Trump. For example, about 70000 Cunanan
associated accounts were purged from Twitter.
At the same time, it's not just Trump being gone.
It's Twitter buckling down on a lot
of these signal boosting accounts,
sanctions on a parlor in so far as Apple and
Google said, no more parler on our app stores.
And Amazon said we're not hosting Parler
anymore. That's also a factor in reducing
the spread of this election disinformation. The
election was also certified and the capital got
stormed and it created a completely new look
at the circumstances for a lot of people.
So I just don't think we can point merely to
Trump being suspended and saying that's why
election disinformation is down 73 percent. To say
it's down 73 percent because Trump was banned from
Twitter seems like a stretch to me. To say
it coincided along with these other reasons
makes a lot of sense to me. And part of me hopes
that this will help to deprogram some people who
have fallen into fanaticism. But unfortunately,
if you believe that it wasn't disinformation,
in other words, if you hear me say election
disinformation is down 73 percent and your
reaction is that wasn't disinformation. The truth
about the elections is down 73 percent because
they're censoring it, then the fact that I'm
reporting this will become part of the conspiracy.
And as I've said before, it's very hard to
argue against folks who are committed to those
narratives. I will say one other thing.
We've talked a lot about the importance
of deprogramming, deprogramming, trumpet's and
deprogramming conspiracy theorists and the like
on tomorrow's show, we are going or maybe on
Friday, but I'm hoping it'll be tomorrow if
we have time for it. We are going to do a deep
dove on a recent focus group that was done with
Trump voters. It's unbelievable. Frank Luntz did
a focus group with 12 Trump after the January 6th
riots and everything about this focus group. Tells
us what we need to know about the uphill battle
of deprogramming trumpets and in particular the
role that right wing radical media has on it being
so difficult to deprogram them. So tomorrow or
Friday, we're going to do a deep dove into that.